a book a book like this is is is
obviously very tricky to adapt because
um right off the bat in the book starts
with a young protagonist who's six years
old and by the end of the book he's 13
and uh you know right off the bat you're
going oh well what do i do you know cost
a six-year-old then an eight-year-old
and a 10 year old and a 13 year old and
that's never gonna fly in a two-hour
movie because you're changing
actors on an audience and it's tricky to
bond with this kid
anyway in the beginning because he does
some things that are not particularly
pleasant but that was part of the real
attraction for me about this story is
that this is not just a good protagonist
who has something terrible happen to
them and then spends the rest of the
movie finding a way to set the world
right this is this is a story about a
boy who's um essentially in conflict
with his own capacity for empathy and
his equal but opposite capacity for
aggression
and and we as human beings are so um
capable of such kindness and yet we are
capable of terrible mass destruction
and it felt to me reading the book that
these ideas of what we are as human
beings are distilled into this young boy
and that is effectively his journey is
to find his own moral compass so my
feeling was you've got to find an actor
who can handle that moral ambiguity and
that complex emotional range
because he's a tricky carrier to bond
with i remember coming to linda and
saying
i'm going to put him in every single
scene of the movie
that's my take
and i think i didn't know that people
tried a lot of other takes and they
tried to have him
not too often in the movie put a lot of
other characters around
the problem with that is you're trying
to come to grips with this kid's dual
nature what is it about schools and and
youngsters being primed for violence
that uh
that kind of there's a lot of ethical
exploration that can be done there is
that one of the things that you guys
think the producers that
violence is such a part of
growing up it's uh
the moment i think everybody realizes
they lose a certain amount of innocence
when they realize they could be
threatened or people they care about
could be threatened or
they could be the bully they could also
be the one
with the gavin's capacity for violence
and
i
people have asked
me not just on this film but other films
why i'm interested in the topic and i
think
and and sometimes they say because
you're a woman why are you interested in
violence what draws people to violence
particularly in schools what draws young
people to create families outside of
probably the family at home that's not
so good they find something protective
here
and it's that dual nature of protection
but what we propagate is violence
is fascinating to
me as somebody who's i don't have
children but
maternal
what is the world that we are
raising kids in what are we teaching
people how do we use moments of violence
to
to to have an educational moment and i
think that that's probably one of the
things that women love about this book
this one more than any
story i know um
had to find a way to
deliver on the
genre of spectacle science fiction
action
but it's essentially a
very much a character story with some
incredibly complex themes
so i think gavin
figured it out somehow well i had a lot
of debate with my producers over it i
mean i i will just say to that that part
of what we're trying to do here
is is perhaps a little bit manipulative
it's a sleight of hand
um this is a story about kids
embracing games that can be violent and
i'm fascinated by the way games and
reality are starting to merge
in terms of the way video games are more
and more photo real
but reality is more and more game like
we watch wars on tv
we see it on cnn
we fight with drones we can be detached
from the battlefield and i think lynn
raises an incredibly important point is
how do you give this audience what
unfortunately they expect on some level
i say unfortunately on some level what
they expect is to get a rush
from seeing things blow up an action and
that final moment even ender
with all the empathy that he's slowly
discovering has this moment of ego there
were many many challenges i think
probably the biggest challenge was the
the gabriel asked for just an incredible
breadth of this [ __ ] in this movie
sometimes you do a movie where you have
a particularly hard thing to achieve and
you put a ton of resources to energy and
you solve that problem then you
capitalize later on go yeah give it give
me more more more shots right but gavin
just had more more different ideas so i
want one of those and one of those we've
got zero gravity going on where the
queen is there's an eras and there's a
formic plant and
so now you've enjoyed the formula yeah
yeah yeah and it kept getting more and
more but um
so
we started off with just a huge plate
to to attack and then each one of those
was really hard i mean like zero gravity
is a very very hard thing to to achieve
when you're stuck with gravity
and having a a queen an eight-foot bug
that is um
ant-like or termite-like and yet has to
have all these emotions i i need her to
be
vulnerable i need her to be aggressive i
need to be i gotta be scared she's still
my friend
he's more my friend but yet she doesn't
have any eyelids she can't blink because
she can't weep she can't doesn't even
doesn't have a mouth you
know exactly so then you have to you
know you ask your animators your
animation leads to please convey all
these things that gavin's demanding but
this is your tools it's what you have
asking matthew gently asking dictating
dictator no director same thing i would
say this is one of if not the most
ambitious films we've ever worked on in
the last 20 years
and that's saying a lot i mean it's a
that's a big thing and you know with
these kinds of films i think another
really
interesting challenge that we had is
we say there's really no such thing as
post-production anymore and and this
kind of film really defies the kind of
conventional
uh you know
development prep shoot post kind of
model
and and for gavin you know
in so many ways the directing doesn't
stop on the last shoot day right it
there really is
physical production and digital
production
and and and both are
um in in inextricably linked and and in
many cases you know the entire scene is
generated in a computer or there are
actors against a green screen and the
world around them is being generated and
it's so ambitious and there's so many
layers and there's so much going on that
it's it's like three-dimensional chess i
think i i think for gavin he's got the
hardest job of anybody
on any film uh as the writer and the
director of that story world and another
thing is like when we read the
description we read gavin's story in his
adaptation
the words on the page all kind of
conjure up different images in our
mind's eye and as we all sit around and
talk we realize
we're all going in different places and
so i think another wonderful thing we're
able to do on this picture is is during
the development process literally put
the power of these digital tools in
gavin's hands to realize the visual
language of the movie
before we go into production so in many
ways he's the architect of the of the
story's world and and now we're all on
the same page and we know what that
battle room looks like in zero gravity
we have a blueprint of gavin's design we
have no question what's going to happen
when we go in there so as we move into
physical production
we're not trying to figure that out in
that moment it's really gavin focusing
on the performance with these kids in
the book the the battle room takes place
in a black those who've read the book it
takes place in a black box
and when you read the book you don't
mind and the battles are fascinating but
when you sit down adapting the script or
talk to your visual effects supervisor
you actually have to realize okay i've
gone up into space
and now i'm going to be in a zero
gravity black box
which is great from a budget point of
view
and sucks visually right because four
scenes are taking place in that space
and each one is going to look horribly
familiar or similar so what we did the
first thing is how am i going to do this
i'm going to do this and one day i came
in and i said to ben proctor
ben it's a glass sphere
and
we can change the mood what matthew was
talking about in that space in every
single scene and i went to the producers
and then when matthew came on and was
and everybody looked at me said that
sounds great but you know how much
that's going to cost
and that's the problem you know because
you're expecting one thing as a producer
and then when you change that idea i
think for the better because we were
able to do each of those scenes with a
different lighting
it does impact your budget and in fact
the truth is we had five scenes in that
in that and we dropped one in order to
do four really well
um with our resources and how to
maximize those resources and i think it
was better for the pace of the movie
anyway in the end um
and then you come to matthew and say
okay well that's zero gravity out of the
way now we need a room which in the book
is about kids playing on a computer in
the final simulation he plays a computer
game
and i remember going how are we going to
make this visual it's a kid sitting at a
computer terminal fighting with his
keyboard a war in space
and i was with my kids at the
planetarium and we sat down and i
remember coming to you with this and
said i was at the planetarium and
there's a huge projector and it's all
black around and and we can do this all
in the round but we need him in a huge
cave and i saw this conductor at the
disney concert hall conducting and we
put ender in the middle and again this
is what you're dumping on these guys
okay there's a conductor in the middle
of a huge cave and it's black and
there's a projector and when it goes
down but we can't project it on the roof
i want it to be virtual reality all
around him so he's literally immersed in
the game why did i want to do this book
because
first i was drafted as you
know it when i was 17 years old which
was very young in south africa in south
africa i was drafted and it was a huge i
was in for two years i lost a dear
friend
etc etc came out very angry very
confused and politically awakened if you
will and
and yet um wrestling with a great deal
of these issues that i think on this
book which is the trusting of authority
one's own capacity for aggression um all
of these things about which way will i
what what path will i take um now that
i'm not at all sure whether i trust
authority at all
and who do i turn to so i think those
themes resonate strongly i think they
also resonate strongly in terms of
bullying and young kids we when we're
older and i'm a parent now want to think
that kids are somehow
more stable than we were or think
no at that age from sort of 10 and in
your teens and through the early 20s is
an exceptionally intense time so for me
it was about speaking to
a group that is often in my view not
spoken to in cinema and we're getting
our most positive response from that age
group which is the 10 to 15 year old
group
who
are beginning to grapple with big ideas
but are still struggling with nuance
and so when you adapt a book like this
where do you pitch it
do you pitch it at the 65 year old
philosopher king
or do you pitch it
at the 13 year old who's represented in
that film who's more intelligent than we
give them credit for but is still at
that very vulnerable age where things
are felt intensely things should be
right things should be wrong and yet
you're asking that age group to deal
with moral complexity so
what's most exciting for me about the
film and the response we get is when i
i'm approached on the football a soccer
field the other day a woman comes up to
me and says did you direct ender's game
i go oh boy this is a fan of the book
they're going to hate me for a moment
and she says i just want to say i took
my
son he's 10 smart 10 she says but i took
him and we had the best conversation
we've ever had
and and i'm not meaning to sell it in
that way but it's it's it's interesting
that part of what drove all of us was
the conversations that we've had with
younger people
and and um i think that was the
the idea was how to pitch these ideas
at a high level but not so high that
they missed their prime target audience